hey guys I'm Nina Massoud I'm playing
Aladdin in Disney's new live-action
Aladdin I'm here at BuzzFeed and we are
about to take the which Disney Prince
are you quiz let's do it okay here we go
which Disney quote do you live by you're
only a fool you give up just keep
swimming beauty is found within the very
things that hold you down are going to
lift you up that's very sweet always let
your conscience be your guide if you
cannot say something nice don't say
anything at all and it's hard these are
all things to live by the very things
that hold you down are going to lift you
up let's go with that one
pick a good boy to be your sidekick
sorry I was thrown off because there's a
bunch of photos of dogs oh that's so
cute oh I love dogs so I pick one of the
dogs it's got to be this guy for sure
the one at the very top he's just so
cute his eyes and you can tell he's
gonna grow up to be like he'll protect
it kind of dog you know what do you look
for in a princess loyalty honesty money
empathy good communication or sense of
humor I would like to say all of the
above but that is not an option I'm
gonna go with sense of humor
just gotta be funny cuz I like the laugh
okay now pick a fancy feline for your
princess Oh a cat this one should be
easy the one that looks most like Rajah
obviously duh that one there okay what
are you ordering as an appetizer on your
first day
ooh for those of you don't know I have a
company called evolving vegan so I'm
gonna have to stay away from the wings
the sliders the chickadee board with
cheese nuts and fruit though you can
make those vegan hummus oh very good
bruschetta tapas how's that different
from bruschetta like Ray Liotta or
lettuce wraps
Oh gotta go with my Egyptian background
and go with hummus here where are you
and the princess going for vacation
Portugal Indonesia Croatia France South
Africa or Switzerland either Portugal or
South Africa I think I'm going to go
with South what about your matching
tattoos that's funny matching tattoos
with the princess there's a cobra here
think we'd be betraying our our trust to
destroy Jafar so I'm not gonna do that
I will go with this one I went with the
moon and the pine trees and the birds I
like nature and I love the moon and it's
very peaceful when I look at it it made
me feel peaceful and I need a tattoo
actually I have a tattoo that's a
sunflower so I said we're all in the
same family here which Disney villain
was the worst ha ha ha ha ok scar Hades
Maleficent Cruella De Vil
I hated her how could she do that to
those dogs Shere Khan or Evil Queen
Cruella De Vil don't do that to
dalmatian puppies take a mood it's all
Aladdin moods
I love that okay pick a mood I am Hey
look nice thing all right
lastly last question drumroll please
yeah I don't know if we put in a sound
effect we're gonna sound effect lastly
which letter speaks to your soul oh
that's the first time I'm going to ask
that question D sey N or I cuz it spells
it easy very clever I would have to say
hi I have got Prince Naveen is the
prince I am a prince I have never heard
of before where is that from who is he
from from who princess in the frog I
know I'm a very rare prints because I
can't remember seeing that movie ever
sorry guys
home and watching now he does look at
Nick though I gotta say is he supposed
to be I hope he's a good man and I hope
that I make him proud okay all right
great that was fun
[Music]